LLTH AT E TATIM
SOHI TS I
TEFIDENIRO ILYMP AMEVENTY TNDHE
WOD NOTAV HEEE BN33 1BE MEMRS
MALIEP RUBNDNSCA ARAEM DOC.TS
, NONO MYRAEM DOCTSN IHE T
SEUSHOE RERAVEL ANBLPUIC
WE GETT  THAHTRASTIGALEV SER
RESICBLAN T INHE HSE J
IMLE
D H ACAN.HEOTRS
EON REPLICA INNHE TEEN SAT
CHRH OEEF LAE ODISNDN IAN M
YE
S CRMOATTEO WHVODN IHE T
TYNOMIRIMOF  ODEEVATCRS EN
NSAGAITS THIIL BLS THIIM T
E.
ATTH WLDOU NOTAV HENEAP HPE
THOUTHT THUNE AU
IZOREDI
LODISCRES.
THATPL PEOEAV HEABON HOREELY B
GINGRI PATLYICOTALEE BNIN GIV
LOALNGWI A DEGERE OTEDEF BAAR FG
UAADINEQ.TE
VERYDE INAATQUEUT BAR F GATREER
APANTH H TNEPEDK. WHEEE
IAM CE TO THE PNTAENGON  I
T
4.OF 6
ACTUOMLYAL SODEBYAD HIC P
P
PHTHE E.ON
INHE TEN P AGOTANNDLE CAL
TONAR MSEOR BOREFEE HAS W TOE
CHIASTNTAEC SRE ORYFSEEF DEN
MCRAMAHE IN  TINARGSRE SOPEC
E
.INARGS
ON A5TUSUGT EL IH, BASVEIE W
THEAY DFT A C IEREAM I RTOREEGT
SAND AAR W HDNEIM WTHA
QU TONTISOSK AUS JT SAYSE RAI
H
UEEES Q.IOSTNS
I' CANT'T  A YLLOU.MONYRE
HE DN'I'GIVEIM A
NYDO
S.MECUNT
THWIT THAHE T DOR MSESE RIDAI
THONESQUTI
HEAS WOT NBL AEO DOINNY ATHG
TOUABTHET FLACIXP ELI TTOP
SEET LS.IE
HEOT GM FRO SRYREECTAFEF  ODEENS
RANAMCMASWN  AAN.ER
OI G TOUGH TSHI INHE TK BOO
ATWHHE T LESIVERE W AND
TI
.KNOW
ASOW A L ILYAS W AIG HHAI P
IAS W AH HIG CEV LELILIV SVANT.
ATOITHA P.NT
IAM CE TNT IOER GHEOVENNMT,UT B
I WASOR WS NGKI AHIGHAID
CL
STASSIT TO ASTASN SITAN
ARCRSEETEFOFY  DSEEN NO
DEAKONSI-MOLGIN RTE WE,HAR,VE
HT BUIDLANE L AOT OFAP PERND
T SIAWHEAP PER TS T HAWA
G
MOVER.DEY SK
ON AUSUGT W 4THASHEYAY D M
FITAY D INHE T PN TAENGOOKTO
RS H24OU
NT SIPEIGLL A NRE THTHE
.
ECABEUSAS I WINAT WCH
THG E
S.RAID
RSFIT AAC AIRTTR  OKSVEMETVINA
HWHICEDTA SRTHA THT NTIG T
ING  THENGAL TKI
UL ?
INES R TNSPOET WOHAAS WLLEG
BTOE.
AN AONACTTK HIUR O SPSEET L M
T TMEOACTHA B TKO M A
UTE
ALACTU.LY
'IT'SHAHE T T'T' THETO SRYHA TT
TSSTARBOHI TS UA AOKCTY.LL
DII 'T KN.OW
THK  BISOOEKE THWE
THE TGUKIONN AS 2LF WD.AS PSE
ANLYTID ME''PYNH UAP VYER
PPUNHA M FYORNT CYOUT TRYHAHI T
S
OKBOOS I SY.IM TEL
,YWANAY LETE MHIN FIS UP
OME
TBACKT. TOHA
HO TUC MHE DOE HA?VE
OK.AY
DI'O'TNO KW IONIF  D''
KA.
DI'O'W KTNOF I MY VOI IS
UO
Y.DA
YWANAYIN COMGK BAC T T TOHEHE
TI
WEE WEROR WITNGKI W
N C'E SEI'R.M FO WUROSECHHIS A
SO IIK LEDIV GEG INTH
OO BK
THUNAU DIZOREDURCLISOS
TEE
E.TITL
IT TTI SCK I ITNON DDAL
R'LDFE'YES E TOE B TOE B
TRNDULHF AAY SER H IET
IS.
E'THE'SOR MEF OM THE HEER AND
MOGOM CING OM CINNDMECO AET G
.ME
DAN WL'E' SEET WHA THE
UTOSPREC PNIOTUICRE IS BECSEAU
'HE'LUS BINFFGO T ASI CONERADEBL
DE.EE
SN DHEOE'' AAV HE T LOTO GO
H
THATOU WLDLYLE CARTA SNDSP U A
COONTUTITI I IALFT WTENO THE T
EMSUPRRT CEOU, OFRS COUS TE,HI
SUOUEEM CRT IS AIT LETL
OMRRWOIS BE,UT W HEEON D''
AN
CIOFFIRE SALEC
RECONGSS FOR T FHESTIREIM
NEDSS AIAFF OICRE SLECE STITA
FOIRHE T FST IIM TEURN O
THORSTY EAERE YRSGO A INHE T
LAOFAY DS ONLI CNTS''
LER.
TONY A OF YOU BLEKSOOELW KRSNO
THHAHA TT ?ENPPED
IS TREHE SOMODY LEEEMET  S
A
.ND
SO YON D''W KNOHA TLIT C
OT
EDVETOHATHICHS I WHY WE
T'N' CVEHA ASIGRONESCTALON AO
.
RDPAON MET AOMHE T MTENS THI
ENESPRIDT WLDOUETOT N V TOTHA
WHT IOM CESP UGA AINESEE NDL
O
AY SND AHA TTRWAT S OR BUEEF
/
.11
ATTHL''AK ME D ANCFEIFREEY M
BO
.OK
HII TNKS I ST OFSSDD ARE
KOUTHT IWINONGLD WTOU UOM CEDWI
EAISTH YRO T THEIOUE QSTNF OHY W
WEULHODOT NANAV HE IAFF OIC
LE
ETETCR SE HY W W. NDOOT
BE OUSCAEFITHF E ENT RSAMENDMT
AN
WDHY THEOU FOFERNDS UR O
UNTR
THERA DERFTSF  OIRETH F
STAM
TDMENENAPPE TO BE JESAM
MAADNSO HT I RHTIGT AHE TIME
ANS THI ISOT N THE TEIMO
REHAVEMO TND ATME ONTMERET GN A
F
CIFIALTEC SREET S
NY AY,WA IAI SD,Y OKASO
UNEDORTHIZOSIS DCLOE URTW
RDWOS.
ESH SOUD SKES NDLINE S API
NO
WSAI IDL.EL
ALL,IG RHT GER VYD.OO
'WHA'S WNG TIT WHT?HA
S SSOHEDAIOW NT IOU SSND
IE
THSOME TG INBY CLAY.
IAI SD H.
,WEL'ER HE'S ALE TITOR F YOU
AUUNEDORTHIZOSIS DCL TE URBY
OL
CYAN.
UY'ON D' ETAVNVE HO TUT PY M
ONAMENHE TOV CERLT  AAL
BT
IT.
HE SE D AITHDEGALEL NTRTPAME
WO'D'ITBUT Y
TBUWA ANYY,E WUPAM CE IT WHE
MECAK BAC TO THEIT TLERE SEC.TS
M HSOOWFYAN OOU YE HER WLDOU
HA.
REVEFEEEEDRR KECNGPI S
'YOU'HERE TRSEL SLE
INTELLETSEG CRS O SEED  HNEANRFO
G LKTAI'ATTH'S RIG SECTSRE
RESPSIONVE YOUOU YR'' LKIOONG
LI
TKEHEUB REPCALINS IN CNA.
NO CI , INSGRONES IHA SRE
R'U'SEUP SPO TDO Y PUTNDR OUHA
UPN HEI IM''E T NOTHENESPRID
OWKN.
OH.
OKAY
TH WAS IIDNSERTU S.FF
IASLI TEL H HNGOWOWLE TITS A
A
.DE
NOUYO ' IW,T'S ANLD O STO THA
T
INO TWTH.GS
UYO NEREV W TTANO SEE ME
AAGUSENDLAEG LISNDONTI AHI T
S
Y M BKOO ISBO AUTHE TSSRO PCE
OFN ISECIOKIMANG
KA OY.
THE PN TAENGOPEPARSOW HAN M
F
EOU Y BNK FRA O THIS ONE
HEWHET WYOR UOKE ERBOS LLSEER
O
TO WNO KWTHA TTA PHEENNGO P
S
WWEREATT HATHBOAS W A.UT
HOWY MANF OOU Y C YOU HANREA M
E
ET M SEEAN H.DS
N'D' M BTE OESODTS TNHISEEC BAU
I W'O'TAK TEHE TE.
RWOTHEHAE,IS WI DTO TOEE ND
YLLOU A LTLITE AUTBOT WHAHE T
ONNTPEAGSAP PERE WER Y SAY
?NO
, BUT P F AEWSAPLEOE Y I'LL
ITSAY BRER VY
FLIEY.
IT WASTU A ST  TDYHAI WNDKE O
INENHE P WGOTANNHE IE  CAMCKBA
IEOMFR V
AMTN.
ACIN FNAGT AINK THA
OU Y.
I GOT BEFRIOO G BBUD T
EFRI
ODINTR.TIUCON
I'O' HKNT OWY MOWANF O Y
MKNOWKG BYAC WUNRODOECHHI G
N
OWISTH HANYEE ND A FEWDS W
N ON OKG BMYAC
UNROD.
TYPRET
OO GD.
AYOKHT R,IGF I W OEYNLAD HRI B
I
OU IME WN'L'T.DOT  I
HETI MENEDON IAS W AAR H PRDVA
A WATASERFT I GOT OUT OF
E
US MINAREOR C,PSCH WHI I
EN
STLIED IN AS ANFF OERIC
EIDNDATGUR DIN THENOR KEACA
GEEMERNYNC I4 5 FHTING
AS W
LYMOST TVE ORNHE T BUTTHA WAS
BE
IUSCAENOT GTE DDEREFRE FOR
OEA YRSO T TO GO CGEBRAMID
UNSIERTY INNDNG ELAHEIN FIS
DY
A ANWONDINERGND A IT FEL
GBEIN AGTR SOND  COLRRRWAIO
YREALAD AT THA TTEIMEAND A RYLL
UTUGROHOERHE T P ODIOF
HIS
BOOKCH WHIUPOE GS .O  T73
UM,ER VYAT P.OTRIIC
IAS4 1 WNHEARHE T W END IN T
E
ORNDCO W WLDAR I GWREP UN O
WAROV MSIE ONN JOHNE WAYOH JN
WA
PEEYN SLLFICICA AYND ENLTED
DEOTPRRUIN MDE  M TTOHE
INAE
S.CORP
THWI TDS SHEANFMAVO EJI
' 'NOT KW M HOWYAN P APLEOEI
GHEND OUMEO  TREHAERMB T
.
DANHA TTEC RITRUEDT MOS OF THE
ORNERI C R APSND
UNERS.
I H METE OIMNC WN W ITH IASN
A
NERIS.
ANOUD BTGHIM H A BTLE WF OE.IN
EAWE RSTA D RE TRAAUNTR.ETOGHE
AN I WTN I M THEINARES
INFEELGHA ' IT'DEE BER DNEFDRE
DDHA ANTEREFMETND A I WAS M
YTU
O RN TE  TGOIM
GTOO.
IDEXT EENTO MDY URRE THE A FOR
.YEAR
THERS I VYLYRI BEFHEN I T
BO
ISK BOOS IOT NN
AUPHOGBIRA
'' AEM MROIAI MYNLRO FM4 6
O
B73, TREHE A ISHA CERPT IN
TH
EERUT ABO MYROAC BKGNDDUN A
ON
NG TEHIT' TH'S VYEREV RELTAN
NOGHRIT HIISW  TS I WTENN IHE T
NEMARISS A ARI PATICOTCAME ARIN
WHM  IH ARER FOSU
INTARSEEC BAUIR A IDM AEDND
TVELODACHE FT TTHA D
INURG
NDSECO WOR WLDAR I LED W THELD
AGGRT NSAG.SIESON
IER UNDOOSTDHE TNOR KEAKTT AAC
TO
BAV HEGGNEE ASSIO ALL I
KNAS WHE SCTAS W ALLUAY AND I
ERSWA V PYUDROHA TTWE WE  IRE
TOUTHGHT IAS W A WIG RHT
ARLI
WTEMID.AR
IN TT.HAO PUD TFHE M RINAREEOL
N MIEA H IADN' WA'T AIN MAR
EYE
I BT,UTE EC BAM.PR
DOUT.F O I
ERWE WINPUE TT ABAG CKIOREGGSS
.
WDANNHE IAS WUE D GO T OETUT
THESAR MIN TO  TGOARHAO RV
D.
ADGRCHTEUA SLOO I RHEND A T
PAT  TRSHAERTHEAS WBO A TUTO
BEARN IHE TE ID MDLHASTEA TT
F SANA OOFYPEGT GY EPT SEAM
GERELRA AAER WEAL TNGKIBO AUT
WREHE TNIEAHRTE.NG
THECT ALLUAY HAD
US JT
ONNATI TIZALEDZ  SHEUE
NAC.
THEER WASYIK LELEO T B
AR W.
I DIDOT N MAN WT BTALINON I
WHS.I H WA
I' 'MOW VYROUD VTI SLLYER
PR
FDOU OACHE T F
HADEE BN A RHTFULOM CNYPA
DEMMCOANRFIS  AA EUT RSLI
T
VERYT FAC A I
EIT LTL
RREMBA TSEASD SOAYNEHE T O
R
T.EVEN
I'EEVE BE. HNER
INAN A PH  WELITMJI
.HRLEER
IID D'N'NO K HWE W AAR MEIN
SICWHHTI MHEENEEDON HNAS W I
THESAR MINAMHE T S ITIE MEAS W
DAN SO IAW SIM HER AFT ARDWAS
E
'ID DN'NOT KI'D BMAN EEA NERI
SO W'E'AD H AOOT L T TKALBO AUT
EXHAPTCE TULI T CO'D'.TAT LK
DAN ITAS W A LEAT 50SENHE H
IWAS BNUTSK I AIM W HTHA
EO
.NE
D SHEAI HE WAS A RLEIFTO PLA
ON
LEERADND A S I'A'MBM EEDRAARSS
LI TASTHA WUS JTG AY SIN
S
FLA RIANCOE MPANCOY MMR.DE
TBUOIHE T P WNTAS IAS W'N'
TYITRNGO TMPRUIM HT I T IST
WABLRO PBA TYHEOS MTAT SGFYISIN
SENTL RAMOMY OHSF IFE.
PRONESOFSIE LALIF
NOT
ONPERS
LYAL.
D ANSOWA ANYY, I DIDT WOTANY M
COANMPY TOINE  BGO BING TO
.
WIOUT  T IFYHEEN WTHROU
IT, SO IAN C MLECEDYEL FPWSLOHI
THE YRLO FEL AHIWSPT
HAD.AR
STHEYCOD AII APD ULREYPLND AN A
EDTEEXNDHEN I TEAR MIN FOR CPS
A
AEA YRND IEN WTANVE OR ND I
URE THCOTH OSEF .AT
ERTHEAM CE AIM TENHE MYHI SP
WAEDRD OER
I IISSBOTHN E EF BOKRI.LY
ORDE TDRE TAROWDHE SSTTHOUEA
ORNCOERMETHF E ANTEDIRRN.EA
DAN I WASIV GEN MST FYIROP T
MANERISON D''EE SKOP T SRETS
AREYTH BE Y ELSEENNFCOID
AL.
EYLYSU UAL DLEAH  WIT ICRSEET
N
.HIYTNG
D THE GYEAV ME A TOPRE SEC
T
RACLEA FENCORHE T S TOPREECT W
R
ANSF O S THELETHIX F.ET
I WAS TO MEAK AANDI PRN LAFO
HAA.
ED ANTHUY GT NEXO TE MAS W
NGKI AAN LLANGDI POUFON R MA
RBA
N.ALTTIO
R FODREXALANIAE 'ID DN'TNO KW
PLICWHH WO WANE E.D ULUS
ITDEEP DEND ON THI WCHHE
PRDEENIDT DEDHO W
WEE
TIFIGH.NG
ORAISELTEGR YPND A WSS AEUM
EATTH W HAD TOSE U P MYNLA
TAIAGNSL.SR IAE
'WE'ED BED WIPUT OND AF I WT WEN
NSAIT EPTGY,E W T VUGHOHTYER
NIAUCHVILYICSTAL
', LLWE 'LLUGTHO ROE
SOH .
YBMAE MES Y,BEAYO NN I TND E
.
WECU EVAEDATUT ABO0 150
ANVICILI AFRS OMRIXALENDA WLEHI
ITASEI B WNGLEL TBO HHEAR
S
BEGBE BOMD BY BHE T ATIRISHND
CHFREN
'VEONNEE BHEBYD  TNEG RIO
FR.CH
D' 'MOT N TOI GNGOE MAK
NCFERERE T TESOHENTRE PSEIG RHT
NO
YOCAN T NNCOECTSE THDO
'I'USLL JL TTEL WT'H'S INHE T
,BOOK IHI WCHXPMYS  EE.IEERNC
OBOUVISE SOMANEL REV TCEO WT'S
ENHAPPIGGIN R W NHTOW'T HAWE
'RE
INLOOK
ATG .
SO HADEE BNOU Y K'W,NO I
'VE
RNEVEOL TDHI T ISNCUB PLIEEF BOR
BUNCSIET' 'HEINS  TOO BK,
,
'IT' SSO RTEVELANWEHI TS .EK
L'I'YOEL TL
ATT THAOI P.NTU.
WIASO N LONR APA COM
NYCO
R.ANMMDE
IAS WSIN  AASOPANSTT NSATERIO
OFR.CE
SO I WASSS ANEIGDO TEA RON UDP
AN
IEBRF.
ROUFF OERICSS A T TOHE
OUCKBAGR T ONDFARSHI WHA T
S
D AN ISOEA RD YOU INHEOO B
K
SSHIPRYIB LRA BICTARINN
A.TH
S HEYAD EEREVALPEYCNCLO
.
ETHER WER AEOU CPLOO BKSN O T
MIASLEDD ET B ONEESELY  K
E.
MESOTH OSL KERES.ER
UREI ADPUI QTEIT A BD.Y  MGO
NASAAD HVE ERYIG RHTO T
NAEALONIZHIS CANALHA WT T
R
AISITHNC FNDRE AHRE AOI DNG
WEW KNET IAS W AUTBO TO H
PN
USBECAUROFE  OS AB CLEE WWEER
GEGIN ISOL A CIAL WIN AARGA
THETIEI RNS TTITUNGIRHE
Y?ONECOM
TW NOATMET HATI IOU WLDE HAV
US
IT ERHELA PNN IHE T
IDPRESTEND SAI OR WEAI S ID'T'
A
HEFURTIDPRR ES DT ENTO
IDE.
RITE HO W WWA TGOO ?WIR TH
BUT IAS WHEPYAP WSI PNRENTDE
SENHER IOTAD H N FOT VED
OS
OC D AEMT.RA
SAID TSHI ISRE AGG
IOSSN.
WE W'TE HAV
IT.
YOU MUSSTOPUSOU Y M.STT OP
AND I MET YATRSEA LER T MANT
WH 'DNEEN  I OARCHGE
THF E
NIPLAN.NG
FOR B THE ITIRISHN ASNVIOS TOFHI
CA ANDT AN ATI INSORTETU F
STSTGITEC MEIEUDS
INETG.
I WAS YOUNOW,ENIG B P
GOTN
ESREPR
TSEN.
SYEMST IOUN YRDEILSTAM DRES
HAD UGI IMAATD NET'OU Y'ETD G
ER OANRD TP SOTOR YOUSIFF OEN
E
HE TDL MIDE T OFAL CHEANND A
K. BGOAC
CABEEUSIS ER'HOENWE 'SOUDAI Y
MUTO SP A WEL WIL NOT
TPPSUOROUHE T PYO INDF N.GOU  O
PTHEY HLEULDK BIMACN I THE
DDMILE OF TRA OHEPE
ONTI.
AYANYW O T,WOOR MFEMSIEE H IAV
ISTHARE AREER VY  TVALENTAY.
E ONIS W, EWEENISHO'R'
FY
REANBLPUICDERE PSINTHA TTE HUT P
USNHE TIOOS PITEIOFN  B
NGAG
AGNSAIT ONESGRSI
ENEVHE WNT' 'SMI COMY EDTT BROU
T OSCLES
LYAL.
DANHA TT WASHE T GTATREESIF RT
IE
HE TSHRI BTIME ARECARIN
APPERH.EVS ER
RTCE TNLAIYOS THIAY DIC NOT
E.T
' ISNH'T G ENPPINNOGHRIT
W.
ATTHAS W AFIER TRIT. RCIF
I P WASUDROF O SHA TTDAIT' THAS
ATWH IE CAMTHNT IO NEMAE RI
SFO
DANERNO ATH R TSOEANT IAM CE
M TTOHE WINARESAD IAS HWN GROIN
HENGRI T
AR W.
WAHITCNGOV MFSIE ODO LONN
G
EDBOMBE Y  BTHZINAS IHTHO TUG O
H
PU IATS  NAZM.
ESTHE OFNCSEE MAZ NISBI BOM
NGI
SLIVIANNGOM BBI, GHI WCHSET
SLIVIANVEHA WTE WRASED NAMT. AI
A WISAST EDIM AANVICILI
DIN'I'T KHAWNO WT THERITISHS.
WE TOI DNGO CHE T OIEITSF
ANGERM
'ID DN'TW KNO W WTHAE DER WENGOI
TOHE T CIEITSF O JANRO FM
N
HION W WCHAS ECTXALYHE TAM SES A
THEAZ N PIE.CTRAIC
IMER WE G ATITINZIE THNA
INNSES RPOHETOE  TOR NTH BNGNI
EMTHOW DNLI KILNG AS MYAN
SLIVIANWE AS BLOS PSID.COY UL
DI'O'EC ETXPS T DOOT THAN I
TH B WARY T, WHEAYND A WEID D
O
TO DHATN VTNIEAMH.HO TUG
ITOU CLD HEAVNEAP HPE TDHE
NAVIET WAROU CLDE HAV GTEOTN
MU
UC MHSE WOR F TORHE
MEETVINAN  TSEHAR  EITVED.DI
IAND FHI TNKSE OORUR
ESLV.
SOOM SHIETNG WASRN LEAEDBO AUT
DTHIS TECIRTNGGEARTI A BUT
E
TIME IN' DI'TAN WT TO BE
ILVVOEDNNGOM BBIIAIV CIL.NS
SOOI I JHEDNE TAR MRPE INCOSN I
RTPA.
ASI WFFER A JOB T INHEIR A
RCFOE.
DNI DI''N' D IID 'TOTAN TNE B I
SO IAN WD TETOE BIT WH MESIN
OUOWH FANTGH H H TDODANS AN I
JO.AY WNE
TH'E' TOM SEO THRU TNATTH I
THC.CIPAFI
WH A LOT OIL CFIVRONSIA ADUN
MOUTHGHEORI HA TN BOADRE A
UTC
NGTI.
ONWAKI ONA,OUAN C YMEEA HR
ST
HECAN L?
MARE?
I' DONTR HEAHEN I TROAC BKGDUN
YILWHEE WOUAVHAOU YR S NDIFOU Y
ARN CAHEE. M
OK,AY 'ON D'TAN WTO TE BOL TD
AF WARRWDS CCHHI IAVLDOU H
EHE
U.D ARYO
AYOK.
SO IEA RD IN THEER INTALTINAON
EDFNIO O WIM TELEHI WEER WONE
ISATTH M
ONSI.
INOM RE THEEE W
I HNT MEJOAYNEAME .
CKBA.
I SICAW P ORETUSFHA WTWEE RE
TINDOG POUT STHAWAII ISBRE IT
N
CHFRD EN
V'I' SEV NERM N EEHI
NCSIE.
WE LER WEGELEVINIDOR PTS
I DYOAY SE  WOKLO AT, TTHA.WH
YOATOWKN NO I WASN IHE T
SRIMANE CN ITTRONAS TO THEE W
TH WTENN OTL L AITEAB HIT YOU
CKPI UPN THE EVECUXETIH,RA BNC
HIC I W FKEORDOROR F AUTBO5 1
YES.AR
IS HSAE YE W G ARENGOI TO
TIIDENH WFYITT. I
'I' US 'N RE OAME THTE
.
I' GVEOTGE TO OFOUT T
HA .
ABUTWAY, IAS WLA GD TTHA
ANERAMICSID D NAV HEO T SEE
URPICTE LESIKHA TTF OT WHAE W
WEOI DNGN  WHE WERDOIN
TOIVHE T C OIAILNSTEGF YP ITELG.
RRSOY T FORTI BHERI
ASHND
CHFREN
WHAD HO TK LOO ATREIC PTUE LSIK
THEYF  ITH
ID D?
ATWHAS WE DON IN THE CRSE
OH
LOR EICOGGALNI AN?SSREIO
I AYOK, ACMECA B
DAN' 'IN MMAKGS THIUC M
THO
.LONG
L'SEE SHE WREE' 'OIRE GNGOW H
CH TE RDOLLEAY VEE  WHA
?
OK.AY
HATMED AN TOO  GTOINUTT,HA B I
T'YOK U'EELL S
AGN,AI I' DO'TE HAV TNE COON
CH
HDOE TSE.ER
HOWT THAESPP ALIATO  TWH''
CO
UNGP?
'W'RE NOT GNGOIARO T TTGE
ANVICILI TTHS ISE.IM
E ATTH WLYOBPRAB
IL WL.
NAS I G THER F ULWARS Y11EAGO A
ASN IAER SBI P USEONCIRESI
GUED WPOEANSO TIT H WRKERATWO
S
FRINTUTRASUCRE SEWE PLNDTSAN A
ELYICTRIT TRESEHO ADDOR FBI
N
ETTARGSY BHE T CAG HUEIOVEONNT
U
E  LSTIKG.USHOIN
ETH EFFTF O TTHA IEA RDND A
TH
REEES AHE TSOI PNTHAT
SEYRRTO B ADNDTH OEROE HERS
AKREWE MGIN WAS LTDK EEAN
ARAIG INAGT TH.
ETHEC EFFTHAF O T HTASEE BN
AC TINRDGO THEN U TOIL KL
DSNDHUREF OANHO TUSDSF O
ENILCHDRN I THEEC DESADFT AER
WTHEARHE TE EC DADTER E
WGULF.AR
I HEN'TEA RDT' WHA 'SNGPEAPNI
REINTE TINSTGOW KNON WHEE W
KN ODKEUT TIRHELT HEAH
CTSTRUHEEUR TRA IIRNFURRUSTCT
H
'A'T' WSHA 'SHENGYI A.AD
AT'SHEHY W T'R' ASY VER
SERGS OUTAWA AETNY
AMPT SHO WASHA TT IBAAM CE
CKR
T VOMIEAT RRHERO FMHE T
WNERISTEN TRO WHE ATE TSSI
.ON
LA UR TEONINERNCTATY D
ION
NGMAKI UND UERINERNCTATY
GALINGIOEC DISNS P HOW
PLE
MAKEHEM WHYHE TE MYAK TMHE
'A' MBES ENESPRY OF
ONSIL
TUACLYAL TT'H'STH ANOER L
.
I'IN GMIVGN IN IOV N OBEEMRTHE
OTKEYNEREEC LTUT A THETYOC SIE
RHE T FORGM JUDTENND A
DEONSIHE TECYOR DMAIOISN NGKI
BSRYVE A
ACTRT.
TH'A'IN BLLE BEOV NEM
'I' NOTOI GNG TOK TALER VY
RAABSTHALYCT T'T' MHA WTIDIY  D
WRE A BOO O LTHN ATART ASYE
.
ITE WROHE T 3OO BK9 YRSEAGO
IT WASUB P LSHLIEDTAS YR.EA
IT M WASY T
SIHES.
CYOUAN GETT ONMA ANZO ON T
E
ONAMAZ OIS LTFELES BTS
RSLE.
YANDW, KOUNOER W TEYHE
AN?
ALLHE T?OO BKS
ITISTST I R
KSAN.
S.RANK
I ONEVLIE IOMIE LL0030N 0,0
UINGOG
' I,T'SUN H PGTTREYYTE SAD
E.THER
IHINKHAT GLAARNDVE ODRIRPCE
T
T 65OL
RSLA.
BUTY,NY AWA TT'H'TT PSRE
RACT BUT I' WO'TE BAL TNGKIB
AOUABTTRACONTH M AON
RM
NOW.
BENWH I WIEELVEL'E'MBE  BBOG.IN
TBUHA TS'T'Y STJU MT.N OWBE
'ON D'HIT TY' TNKHE 'LLDT AIAN
LO
ENEV IF W'RE AN'TBI BOM. YNGET
I'AYLL SE' 'RE LKING
T  AA
LEGAMB
OW N.
THEINEA HDLESRE AHA TT MYAN
RELEOP AG AK MINORAUUNTHEDIZE
SUSCDILOS.RE
ATTH TYHE DOOT NEE AGRENS IID
TH GENEROVNMITT WH
THE
MAESTIS.TE
ETHDERE PSINT HAS BN
ENPRESS NGTI ASSATFL AS.TIERON
THMAD SDA WOU USE AUC NARLE
OAPWEON HIFR  IGOE T ATND WHE
HEOT GWI IT HAOUTHT EENGVI B
NAT
.CKTAED
DAN S
ONECD.
THIS IS A NOWNUT ADRIHOZE
SUSCDILOHO AREUT BZERIDRG GYEOE
TEEATAN HHEOFD  T
IA C.
TBUET LE MUST KEMA ATL LITE
BIO T T YOUTTS HILEM FERRO
TE.NT
TOONHE T CESGRS WAS N
ORAUTHYEDIZ BREHE T PDESINT OF
UNTHE TAEDIT SNDSTE A' '
T
ITHATNHE T HHI WTE
SEOU.
ATHEYIO FREUR.US
SNATENTEA NR IDIUBNSORTINAONO T
H
EHI WTE HSEOUY BIN GIVG HIS
TUACALESTSSNC ULAIEIFDDV AE.IC
ECHE DIESSLAIFD ITO THE T
ARENGSSND WTHA HED SAIAS W
ADATTH SM DAHE VYERELNL UIKY TO
TGIVEEASEHE WONSPO T
TE.ISORTS
GE HIFE M. TTSHE
BIOLICALCAHE CMIUCORL  NARLE
ORO THESE U TNSAGM AI
UST .
IF NE  HISNG BOTEIKETT AAC
D.
HEON T HTH OERDANF IE HS I
AT IEDCK,IST UR OUD JENT
HATE HAS AER VYIG H
ODLIKEHOINF  OUS.THG EMHLI
I ARN CASTPSTRT OO
I C'A'ELIST RATSEN TAN
AI SD
.THAT
WHAT IIL W'AESRL'ESS RBENSPOE
TOT?HA
THED F,HE TYOU WLDSE U
LE NUC
E
ONAPS.
DTHEY'O' N STAYLEUCAR BAUSE
E HEYAVER NEVO T DHI TSAY
TTADMIED U THEOR WDLE NUCAR
LYREDICT
D SEYAIHE TY WLIL USE
NGYTERHIHE TYAV HTHANE D
EYA
NUCARS.
THEAN MHO WEA REVDLEGUHA TT
YNA
RDD MEMOENAIEC VOUNAS HN BEE
YEAROTINS  TIT SALOLY.ARYRSEA3 1
FORLIEV REATH TNGO ELISE RAIS
WHBOVE ERYE  EDYLS THEORLD
KN
TBU THESR I WLIAE'ENER'T
URE
USBECAIR TEHEFFICLSEDEF RUS
TO IFIONRM
SOY BHE T, WAYAM I I RINBLGER H
A
EIT LTL BIT
'LLIV GE HIM ITIERNTESNG ONE I
D UDSTIER CLNUEA.ISCRES
INHE TGOEN PTAT TNHAAS WNE OF O
MYLAOB JS NRTE IHE T PNITAENGO
K
OVPEIPD OT AER L
ER HE.
LYTUACAL A DRECOISVE
THD AT
NTESSE ELLIAYDYRYVEBON IHE T
KNRLWOD T TOWHARI TOT THA I
LO S UEDP WZUENHE IAD HHE T
TANCHCEUSBEO CAI'E' IBED EN
NIT
ISOAN  AM  ROO SKELI AEAF
WI SLEOWSSOME AFRO INHE T
ATSTEEP DTTMARENRE WHE IAS
IZTHAUOREDO THIO D TSRCES REAH,
ICHEL HD THEYE ESNL OYYE E
SOE
ER LLYITYELYAL E FONS LY
IDPREST.EN
LEFIS OFETTEWE BRSETNE KENEN
DANHR C TISFFROISND A ER'HOENW'S
ANBULGD N NOANLIUFSTF T. TKEHA
IIS DDVECORET THAE WAD HNO KWN
ELRYVE W ALNDUT BTHY ISIM TE
YYBERODTH IN D WOE RL
OWKS
PTEXCERIHE T B
SHTI.
ETH ONE I WAS ONT THAINHI SP
THMEDIEARRTEAN
NGBEOFIOURN LSR IAE TRENC
PEESCA A MSET THEEN MOMN
ANTD
ONANTH.EDY EN
ANDHO ANTNYON EAT METN I A
UATCHEARAN I FENCND A PLAEDNN
TH
IR EENTAS IENVONNIO CYIRSPAC
INWHONSI, HEHIC TE WYER TING
TOOMP EEFRHOIS EENR'W'
TUSCAENEYHE KOUHEW  WN'L'BE
TLI
IKET.
NO BWYHI TSE TIMBOVE ERYDYWS KNO
ATTH EEPXCT THESHRI BTIISO  TTH
DA ANDEAHE T RATN SOTHS  IIS
CAUSENYNT AHODE EN S
PLIMY
LYFLATD EN DIEHI IITN IRMES MO
.
SOHE TYON D''NO KWT. I
THR''IK LEEYS  UTHR''
IK E
EVERODY.
'I'SAR HDO BIEELVE
T  THAURYO
S ADLEER LATFLLYYO TIEO
NOD HTAR TOVEEL BIEHA TTY THE
MID ATL LIT.THE AT
T'ON D'ELT TTHYOL U EWHE OL
TR
THATHE TY YOUNO KW,HE TYUD FGE
DANHE T FYTMERA IND A STNPI I
ANTH FSOOR
HWHIC T DYHELL AT. THA
ACIN FT'HA TT'OSS MATY TLWH
Y
DO.
EYTHLS AOIE L AAT GREEA DLL
THIM T
JTTUS THEDERE PSINT NOTUS J
E
ANBLPUIC D OSRTSOCEMRA
PR AENIDTS J NNDOTRT USOU
LES.
JUNOT OC DSTEMLETIRAC
ERA.
AS I HTOEAV SD SNEAIUME H SDME
ITLLP UN IHE T WAY ONEF OHE T
JORGEES MSAHIOFS  T.BOS OK
HE S UMEUMDN' I'EAD H HRDIM
S TYHI BUT 'ID DN'LIT BETEEV ISA
TI' 'N  BVEEEH ROTHUG.IT
VEL ALGO OMERNNTLSICFFIAIE LND A
INNOGHE TY I SAYETOS  B
BE
EDEV.
NOWE 'SNOE'EAT MT TNHA
YTEVERHENGHI TISSAY Y . L AIE
EYTHEL TLS MHUCRU TTH ASIL WL
E
EIE RVTHPO PRURSSSE A MSHUC A
ANEYTH CDFF AOR TOT I MNSEAHA T
N
HIYTNGY  THEY Y SAMAIE ABE L
.
AWELLEXFOT R
PLAME.
I' 'LLU E IVYOGHE ONRI
NOT.
CHAYEYEN S PVIS CENTSIREDE
A
SVERYUYRTMA G
YSSAS IGAY SIN DDA BAYY
Y.HE
VEEL BIE
ATTH OUR INASNVIO OFQ IRAIL WL
LEADO T AOC DEMTIRAC INDQRA A
E
ICCRMOATIDDLEAST
VIHANGFT AER WEAV HE BN.
OMWELC ASATIB LERYSOR B THE
LEPEOPF ORA IQ RESOSDISOON S
HRTFOHEAI PSNTHI TERINS  V
YCO
TRENCTE
MSER.
DAN IT JUS RDEAHI TS ITIME
TH
EE WK.
THAND AT THERA IY  AQIRMLS FHEEE
CO
ENIDT.
ALLLWI FT.APL AR
IL ALOF
ASOO SN AS G WEO INND A ITL WIL
LI WTORARSEER LORERIBATN TSHE
THE' M BLLEURARACTHDER PIO
FRTSO OGSK AINAP JAN ANDHE TN A
CRDEMOPEICAT OIE SNOCTYHI WCH
N
TURN WLPR SDEAO THE T
EW N
LEMIDD RHE T TT ESOFDL MHEID
EEA
.ST
.OKAY
N'HA TT'SHA WTE H SSAY NOWHA T
S
USIS H JTIFITICA T AONND
HEPR
T.IDESEN
FORNC LAUHANGHI WTRY EVEEON CAN
SEE A I PIVVERENTE WAR BYHE T
WATIEEPRMPAN IVES
HEOTR.
ADLETLG INTIE TLO CSE AO LO T
OSUMISETETHF E .
DII PLWAD R .NIANNG
ROUINLA PNNG ISED BASN O
PRTIMPON A OF NLEUCAR A
.
TBUTTHA M INSEAFY THE AREN O
AYETH WF IHE TIRLEIS MSISAV HE
CHLAUNEDF I WENO KWROM
EL IONTRICGEELNTLI OENC
OARFREDRHA WVETERHA TY TTHEN
AR AOUTBO T LAUH OR AREN O
THURAY W OENNF IEREL SCEAT
S
TGET WTHAE' DON 'TTAI F
E
EAWARHAR TDSO
VERI.
YU YOMAIE BELVEND A YOUAY M
E
TBEENDOL ATA CERINAN MYES TIM
EATTH WAI WTND AAK TE THEECON
L
OW ANDE' W 'LLEREV O GORVE
TH D AENDOIRT I FSTND AO S BUT
'A' T NSOTT'H'OUNOS T
RPL
.NIANNG
WEIL WALL LUR O PNSLA AREAS BED
ONOI GNGIR FSTNG GOIDEC SON
FITS AY THEAY S ONEM PREINPTG
THK.TT AAC
TH'' PHA WTINEMREPTEAG M.NS
'I'CHA S TETECANIL .RM
ATWHE' 'ALS TBONGKI AHI,UT WCH
'H'NG USSI THED WOREM PRE
IE
HFORASOT NO NGHI TH WDOIT
PR.TIMPON
NOTT AKACS IN OAYHE T W
.NO
ISINTHG ENMM IIN
'IT' WS AT  TARHA. NISOT
IN THETE CONXTF O AN IENT
R
INONGOTTG AKACREO T PENTVEIVAR W
AN'HA TT'HES TES BTER TCAYOM U
U
ITFOT R
ANOTR TMER ISHA W TTTI BHERI
DAN FNCREHE  WERININDOG
UEZ
ESAGGR
ONSI.
TH'A' WHA EISR'HOENW'S
ID
TYTI.
ASHE W.IG RHT
ISHA WTHE T WORLEHO WLDLE CAL
D
SWHAT DDAADM 11 ARS O?AG
HEAI SD H WER LASIBINATG A
L
I D'O'W KTNO AF INY OF HISH.RT
PELEVEEL BIET THA BUT H
SOIDRSIE D'N' TAN WTR HOEAO T
FOGHFIT .THR AT
BUASITT  WSSGG AREN.IO
D ANONHE T BISF OT THA
O.
I'M GA INIVG BOLKTA AAC AUT R
.
L'I'RY TTOO T SOWP NF IT'SOT N
B TINHEBVK,OO O.USIOLY
IBUT IEAN C TT IP UTHIT WH
EBO
CK QOKUI.LY
HE T B THEISAS OFHA TT NOT
STJU A WDORUT BHE TLI REATY
T
AMSADDAS WTIIO VLANGHE TEN CALTR
PLINPRCI I OEFTIERNTNAALONRDER
TRHE LTASEV SALER HDRUNED
ETHHINE O TRY ENGVEGRDYBO ASEE
.ON
WH IATRE ASGGIOSSNER VY HODAR T
GRTGE A OMEEENT UTHN AT?ALSULY
BUTINNC OE LE W AHI
.
YOGET
NSCO?
SUEN'THS ATA'S ONESGRSI
ONSOMEEID DHA TTLL A A HISIELLS
JU SBO AUTEDPOUPRTS. U
WESE UHE TIR B
ESAS.
THEYHIME DN.OW
DEYTHIDRY EVEINTHG AY TNDHE
N'WERE 'TT TLLHAAT GRERI FDSEN
UOFSRIT EHE ATHA TTOI P.NT
GGTBU ANSSREIOHAT S TOE B
D.OPSTPE
LLWE H,'IN A'T DON GNA TTHO AT
S
ERWHUNTHE E TAEDIT SS?TE
CCIS ATEPHEUT B TISAC FT  AOT L
PL POFEOHEINE  T INHE T
MEVEGORNHT RNTIG
OW N.
IAN CL FEEFI CONRONTDE F MY
EX.ENRICE
YONOW, JUMOUD PEARE. HNDER
I'MAY SGIN MENOMT. AGO
THE CNEHEY WASAY SHIGIN TSNG I
RE HIMAS L NNDHTIG ARO I W
N
ARHE T MN.GI
CANHA RIC SRDPONEHAY
IBSSY
EVBELI?THE IS
YOU KHEWNO TOS RESAD HS AHE T
E DECRAC
INEER A''OI GNG TOE B ANY
DE
.CRMOAT
W'REE W WLIL A NOT
OWLL
DEMOACYN I THE MDLIDET  EASTBU
'ATTH' AS INIG RHTN I PAR
ECABEUS HD WOE ULUPLISPT K R AAC
A'ON D'NTT WA
HA TT.
'WE'UPVE S ARTPOEDUNNY
CTDIIPORATSHNY SONMUS MLI
REVENTESR SELLIAYHI WCHS I A
MI
RINOTYUT ABOF4% 1 O THE
IAIRANTH ONF ISIRE AQNNR  OSU
.
% 64IIE ARSHTEANE IKIRHA CENC
W'RE AON GNAOW ONEAN MNE O
WOVOONN E .TE
TOHE TIT SHIESAQN  IIRINO  TJO
IRHER'LYRES ALANO  NCH.CE
THE DCYOCEMRA INOT  TINIR
FU.RE
AYOK 'REHE'O S NREMONC CHAE
EANTH W W AEERUTBO TOOW ALL AS
E
IZALEDHE WNHA TTHE WNHE T
PEAPONAG PS.ER
IWHATEDEA LRN
BY TSHIIM TE 'ID DN'TVEN
TIONTNSHIEEUT B BTON
M.ETVINA
YESARNE WITBA CSSOMTA AS
CIANLI PPATIARCIDTE I WT SASHO
EVESHOT
AC BK.
CABEEUS IAS AROR FMEIN MAR
E
ANCOMPMA CYOMERND,O SSE I U
ICWHHS I DEDCRESIBENT A LWH GTNO
INK. BHEOO
IEIN VAMTN ISE UHA TTO TBS OVEER
WACPLESEOREHE PEPLHO 'ID DN'T
HABAHA TT NDGRCKOUN'OU CLD
'T
RVOBSE
IAW SSHI TNGCIHA TT SLIVIAN
DIT''RIDIORNA. SLYEE
AER LAT
OT NE.
EJAMIID D'N' SEE
HE TM.
HE WAS DFTRAGE AUR DGINIE V
,
HBUTPEE SNTARHE T WA  IN
E
TILOCA.
DANWY IN INOMGOMN  IWY
G IE
EDMISSHAIS H CE.NC
UNKELILOW PELHE T ONE MANN IHE T
STMIADNI DTIRAON V SIDEETNIEAM
BYWHD O CCLL A A
NTOUS?AN
S HEELIN AINGASTHI TSAR WIK LE
EV MILARY. MAN
'W' HVERORDEA FY EVM ERRYLIMITA
MA
ETHNE OSHO WDOR WKEOR FUS BH
SEOROR FNT CLIONOR FNEA RGA
EVYONENL OY CNSILIVIAE' 'VE
OFARHED  WHOER W NEOT INAMIE VTN
TH
GHOU.
WTHEYE ALDRAF
AGT E.
GSHPUIN WHI TS S AARNDINAYG '
GOOGIN TE B A CK,EWAKALHI WCH
NO
AN SWARZPFKOAY SSITS  I
NOT TOI GNG CBEO  AK.EWAKAL
AYOK
WHAT'' IIS WHBOHI TS ?OK
LYTUACA' I,T'SHE TY SAYT' '
CTLYME A ILLUAY'T' A
OO GD
H MONT O TORWO.RDVEUE
I WIS' ' IMTI SLLIM TYELT' '
SO
OGIN TMEE  BTILY FTE QORUI
T
ROUICON CFLNTS I TDL MHEID
NARE GONGOI T O BE TR VEIN
E
S.EK
ORHR TEEEE WN EKSVEF IM AD SDA
O
AD UNINNAASSSSID.TE
ETC SMDA ISO NOR ME
SHII ITEWAITN S RAOFY  I ANS
ORNO MESEEP RREEATNTIVHA T THE
ENMA WAD MTA DEICFRTO OIE VAM
FOEANYMA Y. JRSIM
AO WHISLIAT CHO
C?
VEI NECENOR TI
INAMIE VTN F TNYUNNGHIBO AUT
TH
NT CATOUBU ORYF SHIDDST
ENLYREEI B B RNGUNTHA Y CAICOL
ORT WHAHA T ASAT IDURUTBO O
RE
ONTI.
TOIE V
AMTN.
TILL ID REAHE T H ATOISRY TTHA
E
AGPENTER PONAP
ITIG MHTE HAVMOEE BN REUSBV OIO
HE'DJEEE BN ORSHWI FLEXA EMP
.
EYTHIG M HHTEAV SNEEE MORHEY
'D'T VISE OTTHN AN M IW.MESOHODI
IT WAS A LTLITE WSEORHA TNEI B
E
ECSHWI BHESEAU T CATLICS
WE
TREHENE OSHO WOU WLD
ORLLCOABITEDAT W F THHE
NC.
'THEYV' BONNEE C BRTVEED
THE
CHFRENND AHE TV'Y'N BEEIV GEN
HI
S  JGHOBIR TBYHEH.RE FNC
SOOR F.TH
ASO CHOLISI PCRENTDE WASOT N
A LICOGALY B W THE
OAYUR
PRESENT TUG HHHE GERENALOO T
AWAS COLS AC HOATLIATHE
TENVCOER
W THLIGHT S.
O OURUR O IAN M
R
IAQS NOTNG GOIO T BELYRO BAD
H'IN A'INT GO B TGOOU AE C
.
MLETL TEELHAOU Y T
FOT R
PLEXAM
SOEA RD IN THEEN PGOTANER PAP
S
IN ' B69YCH WHIIM TE IAD H
Y REALADHIENBE T WINNKGEUL SHO
D
T OUIEOFT  V
AMTN.
FORNSEA RSO AHA TT IN THE
BOKBO' IUT'SEVE UPD U M
TE
, HERESO WEHO ST D ULGE
T F
NAVIET
WHAT IEA RDAS WOM S THIETNGTHA
I
KTHINOM SE PEOEPL IN THE
PAGNTONYBAROBL PEDCEERIVE
YTODAUT ABO TSHIUA SITONTI
BET'EUS 'SREIF DFE.NT
ISTHMU IS E  MCHORENOP
SIGRAGES.ON
THTN VANIER  EAMVESWADI STUED
HI
TORSTYT'H'HEINS  TGOEN PTA
N
PERS
IID D'N'NO KW ITHEGOEN PTA
N
WASE' 'VEEE BNAC BNGKI A
COALNI WAR THERERO FTHM E
BE TINNNGTHAT IAS W NOT A
LETETIGIMA WOR WTH
LEHI
UIALTRAUICST CT TSEHAEN WGWRT ON
ASVEEL BIE
CKBAN IIAOL CON WLARGAY PIN0%
TOFHE OOS CTFT I FE NORIN
S.YEAR
'ATTH'HAS W ITD. REA
THS I TAR W' ' SBED ENTTHO A
HIMND AT THA IHO ST BAC
THALGHOU' I 'MDLA S TOAY I''
T
EAWARF OGAV HIN HITBO ANY.DY
'THAT 'S AOT
OK JE.
IT  JU'DNDI'VET HANY TGETS
IN
ATAR WAD HEE BN WRONGRO F
E
T.STAR
WE HAD NOE MORIG RHT TO WIN I
VIM.NA
CL CIONNDEUD AF I TTST HAPU YOU
OFOU YNOW,EADHE T BNDKOO A
S' IIFT'ILS ST YPUL TS. OOUFF
KELIHI TS TBEO  BEA RDY A LF O
OPPELEHO WLL STIUP SRTPOHA T
T
WAR.
PEI HOLLT  IWIE BND A INO K IWT
A
TBES EN DSOO ME
REEGE.
'I'S AIT MILOPY ARPE.LE
W KINO' 'E LDIKO T I T REA B
Y
OFLOA T AMIE VTNANET VER
OWH TAN WTNDO UDSTERAN T HOWSHI
HAULCOD PE HVEAPD?NE
HOW TOU CLDVEY HEHAITON DE
?
'ATTH'HAS WTPL PEOILE WLE B
AS
NGKI IIE BELVE HEVERHI TS
COS OUT IN TEXHE NT LTLITE
WHNE I
RA IQ.
HOLD CWOUY THEE HAVON DE I
,LLHI T IBOS OK'S' ATHEUTBO T?WE
Y
TH BKOO ISBO AUTE WUT ABOY
CO AGUEAES
MNDE.
HOWOU CLD IAV HONE DE I IT CAN
SE I DN'I'TNO KWHE TIS HRYTO
THWIINOW D IOLA EXPT? TINHA
I 'D' ILOT OK
UPT .
'ID DN'NOT KW A WUTBOL,EL I W
EA YRSTLD O AHE TRT STAHE WN
I
RSFIT TEN WTOAMIE VTNT JUS OUT
OF
ARHE T MNDESIN AO FOH.
BUT C HOWLDOU C HOWLD TS
HHAVED?PEAPNE
LLWE AT ANYAT RE W ILDEA RD
ON
ES THA TTREHE WAS WEAD H NO
TRIGH TWIO N INIE VAM FM TH
GNNGIINNY AE  MORANTH WE
D
MANYE.OR
NYPEHO ATHOR ME  F TANHE
N.
DANO  NROREMO POFECSPT NGIN WNI
.
THANHEHRE FN'HA TT'ERS V
YDI
TERFFENRON  IA EL ICKTS
F.
LLWIIN WQ, IR'HA TT' TSHE
DI KENERTFDIN OAR WIL WLE W
NWI THE RNCISESTAEHA TTAY M
FO
IOWT?
WHOWLILIF PACNATICIOOO LK IN
VI
NAETM AFTE W HEAVAG BADHD
RETWHHEIDE W D IGI STURLLCAYR O
WEID D ITTA BRUYLLS  A
POIT
D SAEEVOD ANLE
NTLE.
WAONE YAN OR WEHEOTR L''
AVE
DABAGH
DDSAAMIL WL NOTOLE B R
NGLA
YEM  FARROW.NO
, WELLEIGHTEGIN BVE O
IN
,IRAQL WILT I OE BLSRVE E?HEEWRE
WI IT BEVER INHA AFGSTNIAN
LARN? O
ON'TNO K
W.I
'ON D'NOT K
ONU D''W KNOHE WO
THN E
IDPREST DON'OWT KN
'ERTHE' WS NOKN TAYO .OW
THATEAM GBLHA TTGR CONSTS ESJU
SI ON ER
VYPORR IES
Y
PTEXCE33OR F 1LD CRAGESOU
TITRPAIOLEPEC OP LED BYRAAR BBA
LEYEEREVY . AARGO
E THICPUREBLD S ANAN23SATENOR
21UB REPCALINST A 21OC DEMTSRA
RONECAUBEPLI ONNEENND IEPNTDE
DSFFJEOR
OOIL LKIY VNGER
OO GD
ORJEFF T, DSBY. WHEAY
NASERIR BDOO LERNGKI VD GYOO
BIRDAI SISIND  HH.PE SEC
HES INE O OFWO TEO PEPLN I T
HE
SENA WHO WEERRE A PNTSE TO
VO ONHE TST FIRAL TULNGKI G
FE
ONLUSOTI IHE WNN AS W IETH
ONNTPEAG
HEAI SD IM AEDSH AAMATF  OTH
DEON.
REI D ETGRTEELTEINNS
H WIISHA TT I HADHENEE THI T
E
LOONRS AH  WNGITONRRMOIS
GR
NGNI.
OTTO VNSAGE AIITT  KNEENDY
YORGET A THE TEIMLSO
TD
NSAGAITHT IST A THINT POI
Y
TMUCHR THO EI.EDCRIT
PMY TBLROEMSN HEWAHA WT D IO D
WH I PECEERIV TRO FMSHI
STOR
IATS NOT EY ASTO PE CEERIV
H
E? CATAS
THISS IN A AIVREGGSS. WEAR
'I'S W ALNGROFUOWAR W H F
ARSH
GLDOU I
WE,LL I' WON 'TULAPECITEATHE T
OKBO.
ILI W SLAYT THA I H TADHEOO L
KO
T  MEET  TATHA
METI.
DOINYTEVG ERHENGHI TD.COY ULRE A
AN TDTHAEA MCE SNTIN TSEHEER WE
SOEMF  OTHMAER WE .LE
ANT DRD AFEAGE LIKLL AHE T
OTNI RRSUN G TNGHEENEROVNM
TNO
TH IATHI TNKLD WOUEEF RUSO T
O
AN ONLY.
MAKE ATATENT T OFIRHE
RE TANSTCEOT WHA TYHEUG THO
T
AWASNG WRO WLFUIT DARO
NOTLOLVIEN
TRAND LYHFUTUL L GEIKDHANIE LIK
MAHE LINUT.KIR NG
TLIKEE RHEOLNT SPE T NHEHTIG
N
ILJASTRO PTEGINHA WTE H CLEALD
HADAN WT USRA GNTDGR AEE
ITH
WHAND CO LATINEE ALNGR.WID TH
AIAGTNSO EX MICATD ANTH''HY W
SEE THROISET M H IIG NHT.JAN IL
THDS REOA AHA TT TTTHAIM TE I
HIONSAESY  DIV CILIEOBISEDE.NC
OUSTCA YE WHR OLTEVO NTR A S
F
MAP PER
ELERY.
INOLWHE UFL WL AOT L OFEOPL
E
IN CSGRONESAS LTK  WEEHESTCA T
O
NG WTERO
SOME OFM THEAT CCHHE T OIG RHT
H
NSR EICO.ENCICE
ENWHHE TYEL TL YOUHY W
HE TY
D VOTES.YE
LDSHOU BOU YIEELVE TTHA AE MNYOR
TH EXE OTICUVELSICFFIA
RECONGMASSNEL TL YOUHE T TTH
TABOU THY WYHE DONG THIS MEOR
TH
CU EANXEKNVETIS NO NOWO OW H
K YDOOUENW NOTH
LLWE,OU YA AK ME NTDGJUME
ENWH B SDIR YINAYG,OUW KNOFF O
ALRCE THCICESTUMAN
IIE BELVEIR BDS TLIELNG THE
HUT HHE WNEIV GESIS HNSEA RSOTR
FO.TIVONG
TYBMA'REHE'THS OSO REREA
S
.WELL
ASAR F ASES GOEHA T'T'
ONE
FOR THESTH OER A BWES LL
BA
ETLEE
THES  ONEIDO WHSA
ES Y.
RDO TEL B TVEIETHAHE T
YBE
SOEVLIE TH OMEF FF SISTU
ANY MEOR TNHAY HA SNEOMT BUWH
O
ATIINNG
NGUNCOTI THI BFKOO O HOW I
DID
EATNO L G TVEHEENEROVNM
IID DOT NWHEL TL NO IAT KT.
AT THEWHIM TE OU IEN CE HLDAV
SE
TOROR MSEOL TD ME I1 1N97
AF TRHEEN PPAGOTAN AMRSPE C
EU
IS,0 700TOAG PE ETSEP CR
HIY.OR
QUEF O USIOEC DISNAK MNGIN I
VINAETMRO FM 1594O T 18.96
'ATTH'HES TIT TLE OFHE TEN P
N
RSPAPE
GE0 00PATOALS L ETSEP CR
.
I CIEOPDT I ATHE T RD
CON ATORIO9  1IN96
TEAFR.
METI IHE WNVEEL BIEIX NONAS W
TOOUABT ATSC EALN.AGE AI
SISTH IEAHE T HTH ORTF .BOE OK
DAN IAV GETO IT  SATENOR
FU OGHRITFORHE T FGNEI
OMPREDISRI HEASNG O HED SAI H
O
ODPE T HOL HDSRIEANGT THA HE
DI NDOT TOONV I LIOASNS
ERA.
TOHE TNGAS WHIN.TO N YKOR TESIM
EREYTH WINENE JO.ED
THE WTOHIASNG TPON STREY HEWE
ENNERIDN THAO TN IHE T E
R OTHEPEWSNEPA.RS
FO JARRWD ANEOIDHEOGLTETR
ECSUBJ A OTFIGANHUNTLE WHI
I
SWATI PUTHING T T OSUTT'H'
SFO
G OWLLINOKE THBO
EPRSUEM COIRT VDDEHE T
ONNCJUTI I BS,UTAS W PUTN O
TRLVE EYUANTLLAC FG 11
INARYES N.RI PSO
E THELOKBO TLSHATN' DID 'T
E
AVTO H HEAD ANY GDOOFF ET.EC
R E THWAN.NTWE O
T BUEARFO RENSSO WHI WCH H I
TI
TMEO I GO WONTOTLDOU N
AMENGLINY
GHOU.
IT T ONEURDT TUTHARE THEAS WN A
CTFEAU BECON NSEIXOAS W S
AF.ID
I MHTIGAV HE OERTHATEV RELNSIO
HOUABT AND DID DUT B IN'I'
A
UM DVEOC
TSEN.
THE H HADO T TEAKNARI CMIL
ESASMEURUTO  TSH.E  MUP
THEOI PNT IST THA HINAVGED
OUORGHARND A M LNTIHEUTR KGINH
EADAN R AUTOS RKS PAAR A
NDH
TI MENEEPL PNGEO
OWHE WER LINIVGT THAE LIFN O
THTOWAR Y N?RI PSO
ISHA W MTE ADME REAZELI I S
D
HADO WN.I T CA
THISS INL OYIS H BRYTO,UTT' '
S.
' IL'VE ' IOT'UTLL POUHA TT
IIS WH IAD HOC DENUMTS O'HA WT'S
APWNO H INIPENGF IAD HAD H I
WO
'DNUL'T HE P OUTUTDIEP DEN
N
S.AP PER
ILDOUE HAVUT P OHO TSEUT THE
YOM SPL PEEOERE AER VY
ELITEDIVOIY DNGOW PTIUTNGR
OUATFOINRMD N IOANENEV
NTCUDOME
ONRE CURNTNN PLAOGIN THO SW US
TH
ATS  THIN'I'T JTUS ABO AUT
CKRO.
'IT'SHE T WLEHODL MID EET.AS
THISS NOT JTUS A DP UD. RAI
THS  IA TNGHIHA T'T'OI GNGO T
EV IALTULY SOLNVVE ORECOSF
NDOUTHSA P OSF APLEOE SNDOORTH
ALL THEFF STUHA TTELUM RSFISD
INMPCOLAOUG INABTHE TY ARE
PU
IINTTGT. OUT
I'MY VERAP H.
'THAT 'SOR MHEAJT.MP IAC
ILDOUAN WTHI TOOS B TKOAVE
BULWODEPE ON O LEOP TY.SA
TTSIERN I THE GENEROVNM ITF YOU
EVBELIPROU YR T IDESEN
NW
G.LYIN
COTHE TRUNY IONT WTHAOU Y S
S
ONA WRUL W.
ATTHILL CTOSAN MES LYIVN O
IDTHBO S.ES
ENTH S YOUCOULHOD  DIDNSER
.
WHAT IH  WISDOHAI D .NE
1IN496ONEIV DT''T  WDOHA
IDI
TH IASN K BISOO D'' TAI WTLIL
MBE THBOFAARS E
INLLG.
'DON' WTTAIIL T' IT'S ON WR
TEAFRTH ANOER IYR SIAANQ RAIR
,A
I ARIA.
OT PUIT. NUTOW
ATD ANWHOSEREV COUTOT  Y
E.
DCOULE B WTHORONGOI T JRL AIFO
10 YRSEA Y 10015RSEA 1.EA YRS
, WELLRS COFOU
I'OU Y'RE I'OU Y'RE AE BLTO
EMCONTATE AT,ON I D''
EL
ODANYB TYOO D TT.HA
AVEYTH HEIL FAMS.IE
EYTH TAV HEIRHE OWNAL CONLACUTI
TH S ORWNFSEEN OT WHAIL WL
NDLPHE A WHAY  THEDOULCOD
ERWHEIS PASLAU H'N'UI QT,ND AOT
HII T I KW WHY FORHE T SEAM
MASREONAAMCNARID D'N'N I THE6 6
IE BHEELS.VE
S ISTH I G OMYWN
SSUE.
HEEL BTHVEIES HE IATF
EF .
DAN HEOU CLD WL BEIG RHTO S H
A
S AHAER VY IC CRDHOAKTOE  M
.
PELEOP WH'ON D'T HEAVO T TL
LVEMTHSE G MESYAY,OD MBE IAN C
REE  MLYAKERDIA FFNSCEEN IE.ID
SHELDOU BNK THIG INOFHA WTHEY
A
OU DNO  AIDTSE I'M T TINRYG
TYOMTHA SE PARPLEOE GDOE IN
IT
SOHA T WE VE FALINLY' 'LL
ND E
TWITHT  FHEAC
THWI.
AOU CO E PLTW HOTQUESEER THE
RE
HEONAS T AWEY NTE.ERFT M
IS HRDE HOLTHANRM, ON IISS
E
NOW.
DISCS SULOREHEATTH TDERE PSINT
TAIDPRD ESPET ENTADBOVE ERYDY
ASNOOU KW,ND A TESAPUTOT G O
ATTH.
SOT JUS THE DAY AFT TERHE
PEAPGIN PMES ERCA
UT O.
DE HHROLANRMAS W STOINAYG HE T
ENESPRID T ATNDE WHEIF IN THE
OVALFFICEOW NAPN O TNDE A A
LOHIF O TFF SSTUAS HEV NER CEOM
TTOUSHI PLATIARCU ONEAM CEUT O
WASHA TOS ATLMEA30T  YER LRSAT
?
Y31ATRSEA LER TBO AUT
PAGNTONERAPSTA SNAS WGAY SIN
THNGOR MNIE O  TTHRYDIORNA
Y.GU
ALS TLHIS ICH B AUNBBF  OGODYLE
OKCO.
TBU OUT O TFHEBL GOBYEDOM C A
VE TLE CAR
NGHI.
YOU C'A'T TRT USVEE THGO.MERNNT
N'C'EVBET LI TWHE ATY.Y HESA
AND YOU' CANR'T TH OLYN REI
NTDGJUME
DAN THECIMP ILITLINF IAL
LY
OFDERE PSIICS NTWH HHASEE BN AN
ACHIEDPT TAM INGN
ICERA.
IT''LY BADUR HT BYS THIAU BECSE
HO SWS TTHAPL PEOEO D T
.
PTHENTSIREDE TAN WTS
DOO .
IKNOWS'T'
ONWRG.
DANHE TDERE PSI B CNTANG.WRE ON
THAT WAS TSA MHEES.GE
IAN WDTEETO T G OUT THE H DON
EA
INQUS OT
DOWAS UMLDNA R
ELSFD?
OWHAS W WORNG FOR NONIX AT
THIM TES A ATE WHISE HOU AID
AN
D H GEOTHE TREIC PTU
.HE
HEOT G TGEES MSA
ITAND S''
UETR..
TBU TLIELNGHE TRU T H CTHANEAV
EC EANFF
MYK  BOOITDSEN W.THH IS
AGST PET LAS IHI TNGTS END
WIIAY  MTRD.ENL DE
SSNGCOREAU BEC OSEFHE T
RESTILAONHEF O T CLMIRINA
AC
TONTIS PREDENTONAD H DE
RUREMO TTH TOTO SPE MAU BECSE I
WANG DOIHATCO STTTE RIT HRAS
OIENBE D S FNGOR MEREVAL
T.
IAS WOI DNGVE EGTHRYIN I CLDOU
'ATTH'S WHCO STTIT RRTES I
INDOG H AND'E'Y MES LATO. HTER
I JENTUS SS TTHIOOKOIM H IF
O
W  KUNOOWH I MN,NOOU Y K
WWH
T SCO OT.TTRIER
DISVENGOI EG THRYIN. CHEAN
AND R NASETORDBYT  CASOLS HIWH
O
TE ANDRAAR BBA LNDEE AE SOM
HERSND TT'H''WHS ATN'S
.
CANHA TT D ANY GD?OO
WE,LL ITN' DI'TTO SP T
HERE
ONLUSOTIND FNKLY
''OT NNG GOI TOP STO TSHIAR W
ANHI TS WL  WIL
T NOBE
TEAVER
IHI T BNKYNYTHG, BUT I
TWO
'N'TOE B SEDPP ASS ER SIE
RSHO WITOT AUT LCOOR ME
.
DAN SCERIACFIHE TM WV'E'N SEEO S
RFARO F OMOM STDETHF E S.CRMOAT
O BERTHS, I CUTAN?HET LP
LLWEAM CE OUTREHE T P HDESINTAD
DO AOT L CF OMERISY B BAUECSE
I
WAS ONRI TAL FHE TYALINLY CAM
E
T OUCO MINY M.TRUROO
CONGNDSSRE U P TERHEE SSREUR
OK
ATOR THEST FIR TEIMHE T
MYRIALND EEDYS STAOR BEFE
TTEVODOFCUO T Y.MOF NE
R FOE WAHI WCH T
OUHRGH A
LICE PLEROUT,SS BT IND EEDN
STAUGU
M WISASAY D1T 1H.AY
AL TMYRI WND EED E TASHE OF
.BOE OK
'REHE'URS OVA OLIC OFF TEE,AP
WH
HIC I RDER AFTHE TREAS W
EDLEREASAPHI TS L.RI
PRTSIDESENG AY SINDE HTOOLNMA
SAIM TE AT 11' OO'CL TKHE
JUEN BURN IY M COMRTOURO WAS
ISDISMNGSILL AESHA CRGGA A
SN
NDME AON TSO RYUSN OHE TDSRO GUN
OFENEROVNMSCL TAMI.DUONCT
ICWHHAS W VYERIC N
TUALLYCH MITASLEL W IDICNDTE
INDIHEEDCT TMOAM SE ANDAS INRNG.
AND T SO WTHAASE, FINHEUT T
IREMONTORMPTA WHI TNG
ASCO
HRENGSSED VADOT
E F TSTIROEIM T CUT OFF THE
MO SY,O THESI PREOWNTDE N
S
TO HD HI
RFO EMPLEN OHI T' I' HVERDEA
CISTH I'A'TA ITMI. TTEOO
FORXA ELEMP ONS THINAAT NIO
LSE
RICUTY.HI TNG
WEE HAVHE TOC RKYUA SITONTI
TERWHEHEON S OF AHI- - TEFS I
AMADENAAT NIO AHEL RO IND'T'
GOOG TET O ON RIMIA ST.AL
DANEWHE T N YKIM TESS GET A
PU
PTZLIERORZERI FINTE SAL
GDO
S.MECUNT
'THEY 'REINRYGO T GET AT US
H
TH
VEIES.
AWHAT TREAMHE NEF  O WD GOIF
EO
TMEOND AIS SATNCTFAIOEADI
T AATND THEHEND E B THE
S
WHAT WEAD HOM CE BKACO T
AA
CRDEMOEPICAT R
LIUBC.
T NOCT EANLEAR MEDONY.CH
A GENEROVNMTER UND LAWH WIT
COHESSRE TSOU CRT ANDHE T
SESIOUN FCTNGNI THEUR CILTAPR
EXIVUTESBU ASERS  AOU
COONTUTITIIONV EISD.NE
ADANOREN SATLAYR BD  F OIDUT
S
OW N.
REMOEROVOR FHE TST FIRINIM TE
THIS ORNY ATH OER CNTOURY THE
GISL WURATETI CASASNG ITS
EWHOLOT VESTGA AINGON  AONGIN
ENESPRIDARALTI W
ITAS WEC RGIMLAINGHHR TOUTS I
PO
RWEF OHE T PSEURHE T WAR
R.POWE
IT HADKL FECDESLESY D GALETENENI
EAARYES
IERLR.
SSNGCOREAS WPP STOGIN THE
BONDGIN AARHE T WOIAS W G
O
END.
IFO'
'LL BINSIE GNSBOG OK
DO.AISTRS
ORHISTYOOKSLF FSTUEARE THE
Y'UNCOTR 'SOWT-ESKNRI ANMENCA
YSTHIORRSRI WTEF O THEAS PT
CADEDE T AKIALNGHEUTBO TIR
BO
S.OK
CUYO